[Music]
stupid Turkey's offensive in northern
Syria plunging NATO into crisis does
this call for more than diplomacy from
Germany from the EU we are talking to
Germany's defense minister
Anakin baba let's start with the big
questions Syria Minister what will you
say to your NATO colleagues when you
meet with them later this week where the
enzyme that's easy to attune instrument
I will tell them that the situation in
northern Syria directly concerns the
security interests of Europe and the
security interests of Germany it's
interesting do it friends this is a
situation where the fight against Isis
terrorism must be continued resolutely
continued we're currently experiencing a
humanitarian disaster with hundreds of
thousands of people fleeing injured or
dead wanted us in Europe especially the
Europeans in NATO are now being called
upon to propose how the situation in
northern Syria can be shaped and
pacified in the long term in such a way
that it suits the region but also that
we need a good solution regarding our
relationship with our NATO partner
Turkey swoons come now to part at York I
enugu Toulouse encrypt button the
proposal of any well Germany make mine
first look is this via in the internet
nautical my recommendation is that we
establish an internationally controlled
security zone in cooperation with Turkey
and Russia this is ahead sooner this
security zone would seek to resume the
fight against terror and against Isis
which has currently come to a standstill
women to talk to come it would also
ensure that we stabilize the region so
that rebuilding civilian life is once
again possible and so that those who
have fled can also return voluntarily
given D of the flourescent fire village
of EDA turkey own you miss Indaba those
of the islands
have to see to it that on the one hand
turkey does not remain in northern Syria
we see the invasion as a violation of
international law so the current
situation must not be extended
diva's land on the other hand that the
territory of Syria remains intact as
stated in the resolution passed by the
United Nations and that the
constitutional process currently getting
underway is continued in my view this
requires a strong European initiative
one we should discuss bilaterally with
Turkey and Russia Germany should use its
position in the United Nations Security
Council to gain widespread international
support - together we should decide
whether to appoint a special envoy I
believe that would be a strong political
and diplomatic response from Europeans
in NATO political diplomatic and what
they appear in the not levy right back
up beyond diplomacy would we see German
troops on the ground would you seek a UN
mandate unlikely as this is with Russia
-
a demanding a full and testimo vehicles
first of all this security zone would
have to be under international control
and where the fight against Isis is
concerned military capabilities would
play a role in my view it is essential
that we include turkey in the
discussions because turkey undeniably
has its own security interests but
Russia has to be included - Russia is
one of the most important players in
Syria whether you like that or not that
is a fact that we have to deal with to
start oh I believe that these
discussions are absolutely vital for our
favorably via the United Nations but
also through bilateral talks the
alternative would be for Europeans and
NATO to simply look on as talks between
Turkey and Russia continues and to
potentially risk turkey
permanently entrenched in northern Syria
initializer took a skier and assisted to
a chi octal huffed you know this is
something that we cannot allow within
nato i hope they're not only that's why
i believe that we must draw upon
everything at our disposal to achieve a
different result here Woodson oomiya
tyrannic witness to come about concrete
so how far would Germany go to implement
this or are you banking on the US like
Germany and Europe have always done
thoughts and video piers of the for the
matter this was a leaked in the internet
nine o'clock the key to controlling this
zone would be international cooperations
meaning we would need an internationally
viable foundations ideally with the UN
mandate an inspiration this one dot
define that soon wouldn't the fogger the
question of how Germany handles this
politically and more than anything what
that means for our armed forces is a
question that must be decided by the
Bundestag as has been the case in
previous mandate take the operation in
Iraq against Isis there we're conducting
aerial surveillance and training
missions that is all according to
decisions made by the German parliament
until now the German armed forces have
always provided the resources demanded
of them by the Bundestag of a few
Congress did first a bonus track from
the appellant was intended what are
these resources specifically if we make
it clear that we are already engaged in
the fight against Isis but particularly
in Iraq then we have two skills one of
which is the ability to train which we
are currently implementing in the region
particularly in cooperation with the
Peshmerga and our ability to carry out
aerial surveillance defeated we're
currently seeing that Isis has been
pushed back but not beaten
its forces are retreating underground
here air surveillance images of Syria
our tornado reconnaissance aircraft and
our analysts help to locate terrorists
hiding-places the hair from da by unter
flip for frontier boguslav I was
finished to maken but above it is also
our civilian military and coordinated
effort in Iraq we are very much involved
in reconstruction in the Erbil region
through our development agencies but
also in establishing how to train local
police forces if you look at this
situation in northern Syria we will need
a huge amount of international support
for reconstruction to enable people to
return to this region I believe those
are the qualities Germany could
contribute your proposal would be a real
paradigm shift how sure can you be of
the support of the Chancellor and of
your own party as a system well
imperfect idiots but this is first of
all a proposal that I'm making as party
leader and as defense minister
I know it's a proposal that is supported
by many defence and foreign policy
experts in my party before going public
with this recommendation I informed the
Chancellor this will definitely be
discussed within the government but we
can't simply talk about Europe needing
to be more than a bystander we must come
up with our own proposals to catalyze
discussions and discuss once Thorsen
doesn't think what of the question of
how you can get a coalition partner the
Social Democrats to follow suit when
they are clearly opposing NATO's 2%
target this is a conflict within the
coalition's conflict that's a wing in
doubt so for some astronaut there the
government first of all today the
government spokesman asserted that the
Foreign Office's assessment applies to
the entire German government this means
that for us as the German government the
Turkish deployment in northern Syria
contravenes international law this is
the second point concerns the question
of how we can stabilize the region that
borders on the territory of a NATO
partner and that affects the massive
security interests of Europe and Germany
ah Heights interesting I hope as Android
fans of baccarat
in my opinion there is also the question
of how we want to shape further
cooperation within the Alliance the
steamer particularly regarding the issue
of Turkey as a NATO partner vivid into
some abide in business via Turkish Titan
Burundi turkey is an important NATO
partner despite all the criticism that
can be made there's a question of how to
act unitedly within the Alliance is one
that is on the political agenda the
sooner we find a common solution and a
common initiative for Syria the better
we can conduct the debate amongst our
partners within NATO zabeta khan via the
dupatta efficient impartment in the hype
and out of fuel before he's before the
tail between the US and Turkey you had
quite clearly demanded consequences if
Turkey occupied an area in northern
Syria what are the consequences that you
ultimately demand or does that depend on
this cooperation from their corporate
school yet societally currently the
situation is that Turkish forces have
crossed the border now the debate is
specifically about how things will
develop in the area I've always made it
quite clear that I consider this advance
to be contrary to international law but
I'm of the firm opinion that we must see
the legitimate security interests of
other countries positions interesting
for Linda when when the festival is that
my conviction is that these interests
must be implemented by political and
diplomatic means aspect the Iceland we
have seen Russian interventions and
Crimea Ukraine in eastern Ukraine with
us we're now seeing it in the case of
Turkey if this spreads it will violate
the fundamental principles of post-war
order in Europe that is why we must
preserve this principle and that is why
it's so important that we find a
solution there that's what this
initiative is about to help ensure that
we prevent turkey from permanently
taking root in northern Syria and their
turkey withdraws as quickly as
in my view turkey will only withdraw if
it has a guarantee for its own security
interests and they can best be insured
internationally you are also CDU party
leader and you've had to put up with a
lot of criticism in the last few weeks
and months
how much does it annoy you that the
convention of you having first stab at
becoming Chancellor has been broken with
spider consular candy dot and frog I'm
fast WAP Corinth water this is so much
kind team it's not an issue for me I've
always said that I was elected as party
leader so I see it as my job to lead
from the front
I've made proposals also with regard to
the upcoming end of the normal period of
office at the moment my fellow party
members and I are concentrating on
renewing the party profile with new key
players and new faces Martin I know
you're home here for knowing and
reorganizing the party so that we are
able to forge a successful campaign at
the next parliamentary elections and
emerge as strongest party's dark super
that is the be-all and end-all for a
successful transition because to
consider how confident are you right now
that this legislative period will last
until 2021
once again I can say that the CDU is
taking this responsibility very
seriously and that we also want to take
responsibility for this legislative
period thus that means until 2021 we can
see how volatile the international
situation is we see that there are
challenges in the economic sector so
there really is a lot to do voters
expect us to answer they're justified
questions and not to spend the next few
months
neither the SPD nor the CDU only
focusing on ourselves Minister thank you
for this interview that you're welcome